feel like crap just came from the trashy
Indian restaurant in a strip mall not
that food though got pretty lucky got
the hottest baddest curry every ain't my
life please call nonsense Indian joint
I didn't want to God even like my
brother and brothers like a jerk like
his wife she's like a [ __ ] I stayed
with him for like three weeks just [ __ ]
to me man I put my feet on her coffee
table she was like don't get your feet
on my cup I'm like who are you ginger
broad man I said that too I said that to
him the parking lot I courted him a
little bit sure but he swung on me can
you believe that seen him for a while
but now got this expensive wedding I
have to go to someone's crazy I gotta
get my tickets and that's the whole
situation I hate doing that and hold on
a second hey hey starting on the
downstairs bits I'm middle of a
conversation I'm here hey thank you
sorry about that
from the eternal from within yes and
hopefully you know I can get like two
thousand one evening you know
and speaking of two thousand one evening
if they've got popcorn shrimp and little
Lobster
stop who goes there
[Music]
silence everything is changing and
there's nothing you can do
the end is near everything is changing
[Music]
[Music]
sorry about that there
[Music]
you